[Music]
the Supreme Court has a lot of
controversial cases on its docket
whether domestic abusers should have
access to guns whether the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau is
constitutional and if the abortion pill
should be legal all of these cases come
from one Lower Court the same one that
also sent the court big cases about the
Affordable Care Act and abortion it's
the US court of appeals for the fifth
circuit arguably the most conservative
appeals court in the country and
strangely even though they're bringing a
conser ative Supreme Court conservative
cases their most pressing rulings are
being overturned a lot you have case
after case where the fifth circuit had
done something that was too far to the
right or too procedurally extreme even
for this Supreme Court that's Steven
vladic a professor and legal scholar the
federal appeals courts are perhaps the
most powerful institution that we spend
the least time talking about in our
public discourse and he'll help us
explain how the fist circuit became the
go-to place for controversial cases and
why so many are making it to the Supreme
Court there are 12 appeals courts
representing different parts of the
country and their judges just like
Supreme Court Justices are nominated by
the president and confirmed by the
Senate that used to involve getting 60
votes and the approval of the senators
from the state they'd be representing so
there was some bipartisanship needed you
had really this long period of time
where most not all but most of the
federal judges being confirmed by the
Senate were you know maybe a little
right of Center a little left of center
but pretty Centrist today not so much
for example president Trump was able to
appoint several judges to the fist
circuit who are different the judges are
I think on anyone's placement pretty far
to the right the Senate changed the
rules first in 2013 then more broadly in
2017 for judicial nominees to only need
50 votes for confirmation and removed
the home state approval rule so Trump's
ninees no longer needed bipartisan
support you're seeing the sort of the
norm for judicial confirmation be you
know who is the most
ideologically extreme person I can get
through the Senate today for obvious
reasons that changes the calculus for
what kind of person you're looking for
so Trump nominated judges and justices
who had extensive and controversial
records unlike previous appeals court
judges who typically had backgrounds in
private practice or as judges in other
courts most of Trump's judges at least
in the fifth circuit also had political
backgrounds either working for campaigns
the White House or directly for the
governor and attorney general they now
hear cases from I actually think that
many of the judges that we're seeing
nominated during the Trump
Administration and confirmed during the
Trump Administration and indeed many of
the judges we're seeing nominated during
the Biden Administration and confirmed
today would never been nominated during
prior presidencies of the same party and
you know I think folks will have
different views about whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing what I think
we can't deny is it's a thing and it's
having a pretty profound effect on the
nature of the federal Judiciary but the
judges alone can explain the
controversial cases they don't make them
up part of it is litigant steering cases
to these judges the modus operandi is to
file in Texas where you can find a
sympathetic district judge where you
know that any appeal is going to the
fifth circuit the case against the
abortion pill was filed in Amarillo
Texas because the district judge there
the court that hears the cases before
the appeals court does is very
conservative dobs was brought in
Mississippi and the fifth circuit judges
can even make the system work in their
interest when a case comes to the court
of appeals it's assigned to a panel of
three random judges at the fif circuit
the odds are pretty good that a case
will be heard by a majority of
conservative judges but sometimes a case
gets a majority of liberal judges like
with a case involving whether felons
should have the right to vote in
Mississippi the panel ruled they should
but the full court can decide to rehear
cases by the entire court what's called
onbon which it plans to do for that
felon one in January folks tend to use
the term judicial activism as a
shorthand for decisions they disagree
with um and I think that in that respect
the term is unhelpful there is however I
think something that is especially
aggressive um about the way the fifth
circuit's behaving not just in the
substance of the decisions that the
Court's handing down but also just in
its procedural behavior um so one great
example of this was the challenges to
the Biden administration's vaccination
or testing mandate for large employers
immediately dozens of nearly identical
lawsuits challenging the rule were filed
in different states so many that every
Circuit Court in the country would have
heard the same case it triggered a
literal Lottery each court with the
pending case would have a ball put into
a wooden drum and whoever had theirs
picked out would hear the case but
before that Lottery happened the fist
circuit cut ahead and ruled on the case
anyway blocking the Biden
administration's mandate after the
lottery the winning Court reversed it
and allowed the policy to go into effect
it's not just that you have judges all
the way to one side of the ideological
Spectrum who are being aggressive in
adopting and pushing for new
interpretations of what had been pretty
settled legal Concepts it's that they're
taking procedural shortcuts and I think
that's part of why we're seeing
increasingly a disconnect between the
conservative judges on the fifth circuit
and the conservative justices on the
Supreme Court you know some of whom I
think are much more particular about
those procedural formalities president
Trump was able to appoint a large number
of polarizing judges President Biden has
done some of the same thanks to that 50
vote rule but not as polarizing as the
Democratic Senate has mostly taken the
home state approval rule back up I think
the real problem at the end of the day
is you might be happy with individual
results and individual cases um but our
legal system is not set up for a world
in which you can have this kind of
radical polls um with no middle what
that really is a recipe for is chaos um
and not a set of coherent uniform legal
principles that actually might allow us
to function as one nation as opposed to
50 different states with the fifth
circuit filled with conservative judges
it will continue to attract the most
conservative cases some of which will
inevitably end up at the Supreme
[Music]
Court